well tickets are wonderful tea yeah I
don't know if you knew this but their
Tufts are made out of rubber there but
of the middle of Springs they're bouncy
bouncy bouncy bouncy fun fun fun fun
bang a bottomless wonderful thing about
Tiggers design the only one I'm the only
one so stick that in your and you'll be
singing that at dinner Jim Cummings is
the voice behind hundreds of characters
like Tigger and darkwing duck and duck
and I gotta get a shorter intro look at
that quick duck I was the terror but
flap them a night so there you have it
speaking of dark Wayne what was it like
coming back to her price reprise him for
dump cocktails well that was a ball but
it was too short lived
too short lived everything short lived
and some people sick keep saying for
some reason they think he had a cameo
it's so funny because actually it was a
Darkwing Duck cartoon with a cameo of
duck Hills wrapped around it that's
right
I just want to straight that up perhaps
most notably Jim is back as Winnie the
Pooh and yes a Tigger too for
Christopher Robin oh how did you know
was there any apprehension of reprising
Pooh in a live-action sense it's got to
be such a great feeling to me you know a
voice that can call kids call them leave
voicemails yeah
noria most frequently asked to what to
do well well Pooh and Tigger they're way
up there Darkwing Duck is a biggie yeah
sure and a lot of people and oddly
enough these are some of my favorites so
maybe there's a correlation but
everybody seems to love ray from
Princess and the Frog the lovesick
Firefly good women they like a man with
a big back coach you know that's right
and I love Hondo
Hondo a akka from Star Wars Clone Wars
yes and I'm glad other people do thanks
yeah people do you know there's a lot of
Clone Wars is coming back so yeah
yeah I have been cutting the call little
subtle hit there that's right yeah and
they we have resistance and forks you
are you gonna be doing anything with
them I will not be resisting if they
call you will not be resisting if they
MA see how I work then I like what you
did there Thanks
how did you know that you wanted to be a
voice actor was not something you'll
kind of always had a knack for and
people were pointing out to you yes I
was a very annoying child I would you
know I always say oh you know doing
dolphins in the back of the room and
then that and I I just it worked you
know I remember when I was a kid my dad
pointed out Mel Blanc on the check Benny
program he said you see this guy here
and listen yeah he's the guy that does
that Tazz and foghorn and bugs and Daffy
all those cartoons you like on Saturday
want to have that Wow
he's not getting into trouble he doesn't
have to stand in the corner for being
turbo loud or whatever or interrupting
and so I thought that would be a pretty
good way to go when it's so far so good
yeah it's you're doing pretty well we're
good did you have like what advice would
you have for a young actor who wants to
get into voice work well remember that
you are people said when you do this
voice that place okay that's true but
first and foremost you are an actor and
we're all character actors we're
character actors and we're doing
characters first and the voice is second
you know that these are this is a
character that's a character this that's
just what they sound like when they talk
right and you think of it that way and
it's a better approach I think well
thank you so much Jim pleasure to talk
to you
you
[Music]